The radio is powered by electricity from a wall socket at not a battery.
It can be controlled by two manual knobs. One for volume on the top right and
one for tuning on the right side. The chosen frequency is displayed on
the right side of the front panel with a small vertical white bar.
The display features a twelve hour clock on the left front and
two small lights. The light in the upper left hand corner of
the display labeled AM indicates whether the displayed time is in the morning,
when the light is off or in the afternoon or evening when the light is on.
The light in the lower right hand corner of the display is labeled wake.
If it is lit indicates you have armed the alarm. In addition to the above,
the radio has two switches and five buttons. One of the switches on the top edge
of the back determines whether the frequency band is set to AM or FM.
The second switch found in the center front of the top has four positions.
The switch slides horizontally from left to right. In order,
the positions indicate whether the radio is on, off, armed for wake by radio or
armed for wake via a beeping sound. Four buttons are found on the left side of
the top of the radio. They can be used to set various timers in the clock.
They are labeled hour, min, wake, and sleep. By pressing the wake button,
you can set the time you wish the alarm to go off. By pressing the sleep button,
you can set how long you would like the radio to play before automatically
shutting off. Using this feature allows you to fall asleep with the radio
playing. If neither button is pressed you can set the current time of day.
You've actually set these three timers using the other two button on the front
left of the top of the radio, they are labeled hour and min. By pressing hour
you increment the hour of, of the respective timer, the wake, sleep or time of
day timer. Similarly for min, if you wish to be awakened 15 minutes later
tomorrow morning than you were this morning you would hold down the wake button
while pressing the min button 15 times. The final button is the snooze button.
It is the large button found in the center front of the top of the radio.
The snooze button is useful when the alarm is trying to wake you up.
Each time you hit the snooze button the alarm shuts off for
10 minutes. The final feature to note about the radio is that the alarm will
automatically turn itself off after one hour, to prevent the situation where you
forgot to turn it off and it was audible all day long.